russia at war its president says it's
demilitarizing and denazifying ukraine
european leaders call it an outrageous
invasion how far will putin go
can the west stop him this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan well it's a war that no one you
would think would have wanted but
overnight russian forces began a
full-scale invasion of ukraine it's the
largest military action in europe since
the second world war already casualties
are mounting on both sides russian
forces are attacking major cities and
military bases ukraine says it's ready
to fight and repel the incursion nato
has activated its defense plans while
western powers are promising harsh
sanctions against moscow's economy some
ukrainians are fleeing to neighboring
poland
just shattered shattered not for myself
not i don't care about my hood safety i
just i care about ukraine she has family
and ukrainians
i'm a ukrainian heritage and to see
this happening to the country is just
devastating
i just
i just can't believe someone could be so
evil
president vladimir putin announced the
invasion on a televised pre-recorded
address telling ukrainian troops to go
home or face the consequences
we urge you to lay down arms immediately
and go home i will explain all
servicemen of the ukrainian army who
comply with this requirement can freely
leave the area of military actions and
return to their families
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history we are ready for
any outcome
u.s president joe biden released a
statement calling russia's attack on
ukraine unprovoked and unjustified
saying
president putin has chosen a
premeditated war that will bring a
catastrophic loss of life and human
suffering russia alone is responsible
for the death and destruction this
attack will bring and the united states
and its allies and partners will respond
in a united and decisive way the world
will hold russia accountable
nato's secretary general jens
stoltenberg says the alliance wants to
prevent a conflict but is ready to
defend itself
nato's core task is to protect and
defend all allies
there must be no room for miscalculation
or misunderstanding
an attack on one
will be regarded as an attack on all
this is our collective security
guarantee
today the north atlantic council decided
to activate our defence plans
at request of our top military commander
general todd walters
this is a prudent and defensive step to
protect and shield allied nations during
this crisis
and it will enable us to deploy
capabilities and forces
including the nato response force to
where them are needed
well let's bring in our guests into the
show we have joining us from kiev sergey
tsukach he's the ceo of ukraine invest a
ukrainian government agency in moscow
vladimir sotnikov a senior research
associate at the russian academy of
sciences and from washington d.c
lawrence korb a former u.s assistant
secretary of defense welcome to all of
you in the show if i could start with
sergey then
what do you make sergey
of
putin's military goal what's the
thinking in kiev do they think he is
going to try and take over the whole
country
well it's the beginning of a full-scale
invasion of ukraine
this is a very dangerous thing
and we have seen already victims of this
invasion
and not only key for the border was
attacked even cities like six or seven
hundred kilometers away from kiev
cities in the west of ukraine were
attacked by russian missiles
so let me
be very clear this is beginning of the
european genocide
through
the war
of a very big scale
but ukraine will not back down
we are fighting back and at the moment
there are fights around kiev and already
russian planes took down
and tanks as well and helicopters
so this is a very serious case
and this is a very serious case not only
for ukraine
this is a very serious case for the
whole world right because if russia will
not be stopped now this can spread
throughout the europe and throughout the
world so let me be clear about that okay
talking about russia let's get the
perspective from moscow now and i want
to ask vladimir when
president putin announced this operation
he said the goal is not to occupy but to
demilitarize and denazify how do you
demilitarize a country without occupying
it well actually that's correct but
first of all i would like to say good
good afternoon probably to all the tv
watchers
and i also i would like to disagree with
my uh ukrainian colleague because it
sounds like propaganda actually no i
mean that uh
russia is not aiming at uh um conquering
or even invading or something like that
of all ukrainian territory and russia
certainly is not going to further more
to go to go further more as he put it so
if i understand correctly that russia is
going to threaten the eastern europe so
answering that question i think that uh
demilitarization of ukraine could be
done when uh all the military units i
mean uh military unions who are shelling
the peaceful citizens of
uh
donetsk and lugansk republic
uh will will will be will will be uh
will be eliminated and when
there will be a situation that uh
nothing would be uh dangerous for the
citizens of donetsk and the lugansk
republics so the suggestion seems to be
then are you saying vladimir in your
understanding
that putin simply wants to eliminate
ukraine's military abilities
that seems a very
difficult i'm not i'm not i'm not
contemplating that i mean i i don't know
actually i i'm not a state governor a
state employee i don't know i'm just
asking in your understanding or analysis
of this this is just my understanding
that's right let's bring lawrence corbyn
uh lawrence
how long
can the ukrainians hold out in the
estimations of washington
well i think they can hold out for a
long time in two ways first of all
with their conventional forces which are
much better than they were in 2014 the
last time
russia invaded and with the
with the increasing uh equipment that we
have given
we have given them
uh that uh you know makes them more
lethal then the second thing is even if
the russians should prevail in a
conventional war the question then
becomes uh you know what about an
insurgency the ukrainians have been
organizing an insurgency for a while
and as the russians found out in
afghanistan and we did too it's one
thing to win the conventional battle but
it's much more difficult to control the
country and i guess the real question
i'd like to see answered is what is
putin's aim here does he want to
incorporate ukraine back into russia
does he want to put in a friendly
government there and how will he how
long is he willing to pay the cost of
dealing with it for the lives and then
of course with the sanctions that not
just europe but asian countries like
japan singapore
and taiwan are putting on russia
a lot for us to pick
out there let's go back though to sergey
and take stock of what's happened so far
sergey how much damage have these
airstrikes or missile strikes dealt to
ukraine's critical infrastructure as far
as we know at this point electricity is
still up and running fuel depots as well
as the military bases of course
well we have seen attacks on our
strategic
targets of course but still ukraine
fights back so our military
is getting ready and already given some
very good response to
russian aggression so there is no
serious effect at the moment on ukraine
and i think that idea of putin is to
make a very quick war and to win equip
this will not happen in ukraine and let
me respond to
that
nonsense i apologize for this statement
but today i can say uh said by the
russian
speaker ukraine is a peaceful country
and the only one who needs to be
demonized
is the russian federation and the
president of russian federation and his
militant friends they should be put to
international tribunal
as a criminals
against
criminal
things that they do against humanity you
know and this is a very serious case and
let me remind you one historical case
the 30th of september 1938 when the
sudet region of czech republic was given
through peaceful treaty to adolf hitler
and this is what he was trying to do at
the time so this is very similar what
president is putin doing now and only
one year after 1938 the second world war
began so this is what the whole world
needs to remember now so we are very
close we are on the brink of something
similar so they need to back down and
they need to apologize to the whole
world and they will have to be put to
prison for this let's see how this goes
let me bring vladimir back in and once
again pointing out vladimir i know
you're not an official spokesperson
you're not an official for the russian
government so i'm just asking you for
your analysis
um does it look like we're going to be
looking at the sort of scenario which a
lot of western intelligence agencies
were warning about that there will be an
initial period
of strikes airstrikes missile strikes
followed maybe a week or so later by a
wider deployment of ground troops is
that what we're looking at
no i don't think so actually my analysis
is
that there will be uh strikes uh
targeted strikes against the military
installations in uh ukraine and uh
after that there will be
uh
that is a limitation of all the special
uh operation and after that
uh there will be the end of uh the
military operation i i i'm not
contemplating that
there will be occupation so-called
occupation of uh ukrainian territory
do you really think it's possible though
that vladimir putin will pull out
russian troops completely
well
completely out of ukraine might be a
tall order given the situation in
donbass and and crimea but at least
not beyond the donbass
sorry for my interruptions so please
sorry for my interruption we're not
talking right now about
donbasque and donbass and lugansk
republics because this is independent
states who are asking formally for the
support and defense from uh russian
federation so this is according to
national law with in accordance with
article 51
part 8.
well international according to
international law would a lot would
dispute whether lugansk and and don
yetzk are indeed independent republics
we know russia has recognized them but
moving beyond that let me bring lawrence
back in
i mean
a situation you were hinting at
afghanistan
or iraq
do you think
lawrence putin would be weary of sending
his troops deep into ukraine especially
as we get towards western ukraine is it
likely that we will see a situation
where
russian troops will be pulled back to
the eastern and southern parts of
ukraine at least rather than getting
embroiled into some kind of long-term
guerrilla conflict
well you could see that but then what is
your goal who's going to be running
ukraine will you still have zilinski
there will you try and put your own uh
you know leader in there and will the
ukrainian people support him and not
create it in surgery that's the real
question because if you're not willing
to go all the way militarily
uh then what do you do if you haven't
achieved your objective today we've seen
of course
this massive operation an invasion
that many are calling an invasion of
ukraine does this mean the end of the
road
for diplomacy let's not forget just a
few days ago there was talk of even
perhaps a biden putin meeting all that
seems very distant now
i'm not representing ministry or foreign
affairs of ukraine so and ministry of
foreign affairs can give you a proper
political statement about diplomatic
measures that can be taken or are being
taken at the moment
what i can state
as a ukrainian mostly because my main
job is to attract investments and
promote economy in ukraine but today i
am an average ukrainian who was affected
my mom
who is
73 years old was woke up today i was
waking up today in ivana from
by an air response siren
and there was a missile going over the
city to hit one of the targets
so this is a crime i am a lawyer i'm
international lawyer this is crime
against humanity so we need to focus on
that
rather than
think about what can be done on the
ground or not russian military have
their plans ukrainian military is strong
and we will we are fighting back so it's
all about military and they have their
own plans right but we need to be clear
the crime has taken place okay well let
me go back to lawrence corp lawrence
western countries have announced another
round of sanctions how effective do you
think they'll be russia has been under
sanctions for a long time hasn't it
yes but never to this extent and i think
one of the big thing is when the germans
canceled the nordstream pipeline because
how russia makes a lot of its
money by selling energy abroad and if
they can't do that that's going to have
an impact on on their economy
keeping them away from the international
banking system will make it more
difficult for them to
uh conduct business
they have to
export things like wheat are people
still going to buy that so it'll they're
going to pay a price the question is how
long is putin willing to do that and how
long will the russian people do and if
you go to a ground war they're going to
be lots of casualty you'll probably be
more on the ukrainian side but you're
talking about five to ten thousand
russian soldiers being uh killed and
don't forget the russians still have
conscription so that these are people
are not volunteers a lot of them have
been forced in there so what we need to
do is find a face-saving way out before
my colleague
from ukraine pointed out this thing gets
out of hand and it'll be a disaster
let's take the view from moscow in your
analysis vladimir russia has large
reserves
about 600 billion dollars that's about
40 percent or more of its gdp that's
more reserves than most countries how
far will that go
to cushioning the effect of western
sanctions uh do you think people the
policy makers in moscow are worried
about western sanctions
i think yes i think yes you know
there are two actually uh things
analytically speaking uh uh
which are going after your question
first the first thing is that
moscow actually has used to live under
sanctions and somehow
uh
russian government actually managed to
redeploy
economic resources and financial
resources under these promoting
sanctions which have been going on for
for already uh eight years
after the 2014. and second second
element is that uh
i think
probably there will be some worsening of
economic conditions in russia and uh
because of
the exchange rate ruble to dollar you
know that ruble is now declining and
dollar is rising but eventually
eventually russia has a lot of so-called
sovereign resolve just to make
make currency intervention foreign
currency interventions and i think
eventually this bad effect will be again
eliminated
okay this is my analysis
all right let's get sergey from kiev so
sergey
it sounds like
the leaders in ukraine are not entirely
satisfied with the western response and
they they think
western countries should do far more
well we are thankful to all leaders for
what has been done so far
we're thankful to our neighbors like
lithuania latvia you know other
countries that provided
weapons to ukraine we're also thankful
to european union and american friends
for sanctions
but
we need to remember that this is a
russian operation under a false flag as
was rightly stated by president biden
and the
one way to affect russia is to limit
economic and stop economic cooperation
with russia at the moment and this has
to be done quick we need to remember
that one third of energy supplies to
europe comes from russia
and all this money that are spent on
russian energy
is being used to produce weapons
and to
act as a tyrant you know in a 21st
century and to
make a war in the center of europe so
this is unacceptable so as i said we
want to see very strong international
response and very quick international
response what kind of international
presidency do you think
most ukrainians would like to see sergey
beyond what the west has already done
well we of course would be keen to see
some military support
but as we have you mean beyond simply
supplying weapons because it's unlikely
where any western leaders have already
said they're not sending their troops
to ukraine we understand that this is
unlikely we want to see military support
in different terms but we also want to
see
real serious sanctions on ukraine to
break down their economy not just russia
yes on russia on russia of course yes
not for the sake of bringing kind of i
don't know
bad
situation to the people of russia but to
stop them using money for military
purposes and this is what needs to be
done quick because
i can tell you
that predators they do not stop
themselves predators they need to be
stopped
all right let me take the view back
again to moscow and ask vladimir in your
analysis vladimir if the west does
succeed in putting the squeeze on on
russia over ukraine what are the chances
that maybe russia will find other
sensitive spots soft spots to have a go
back at the west have a go back at nato
maybe in areas like the balkans there's
talk of
russian-leading bosnian serbs being
involved in a war in bosnia
uh if i understand you correctly you
mean what are the russian further
actions you know whether it will be
involved in the conflicts uh
in the conflicts in bosnia or while in
baltic states am i correct in my
understanding or maybe not involved but
may assist shall we say or facilitate
conflicts that would be a problem and a
burden for nato in places like the
balkans yes
no no i don't think so my mineral as a
section that
there will be no such interference on
the russian side uh to go to other
other frozen conflicts and not frozen
even live conflicts like uh uh
those who which are going in in in in
balkans or
conflicts which are going uh i mean
internal crisis
in in baltic states i think that this is
actually look this is not the purpose
this is not the purpose of moscow this
is just
uh
uh the situation when uh
there was a loss loss of confidence uh
on behalf of moscow
in my opinion towards the west and
especially to watch the ukrainian
authorities because moscow has suggested
i'm just in reiterating myself
moscow has suggested any peaceful uh
means
to
prevent the situation this situation
which is having now uh in ukraine
all right i think we've got a couple of
minutes we're going to try and split it
between both guests so we get a final
thought in sergey
how much of a game changer do you see
this for the whole of europe
let me react again to that statement
it's a typical russian propaganda if you
listen to putin's statements i cannot
call him president or mr at the moment
even that
if you listen to putin's statements like
ten years ago eight eight years ago he
was saying that there is no way that we
would take crimea back
then he was saying that there is no way
that we would act at the east of ukraine
or anywhere in ukraine just couple of
days ago they were saying there is no
way that we will attack kiev right now
they're saying there is no way we will
attack balkans or any other state so
obviously a lot of the deficits they can
do this right they can do this we've got
about 60 seconds
all right we've got about less than 60
seconds then okay let me give also a
final well might be less than six
seconds now to vladimir vladimir why
should the world believe russia isn't
this a bit of a game changer in
international politics many would say
you know invading a sovereign state
that's a no-no in the basics of
international law in the un charters
well actually i think that eventually
my uh belief
that eventually the diplomacy will win
what i mean to say that
there are there were
disruptions and violations on behalf of
ukrainian authorities other people
in donetsk and lugansk republics so
let's forget about international law
let's go to the diplomacy
okay we're out of time we're going to
have to leave it there so let's thank
our guests
let's thank our guests very much in kiev
and moscow for coming and sharing their
thoughts we know you have very different
perspectives on this but we appreciate
hearing them
sergey tsukach vladimir sotnikov and
lawrence korb and thank you too for
watching you can see the show again
anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com
for further discussion head over to our
facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story from me sami zaydan and the
whole team here for now is goodbye
[Music]
you